は今後
ん
def カップ
aa グットはこれじゃなかったほんじゃあね社長です俺の夏は終わっちゃい名という
わけで超巨大な聖火を準備しましたこれ不安定
酒造罪行レベルで結構調教 m スイカを張ってみました山形県から山形県のスイカ
っぽいんですけど皆さんアルコール suica って聞いたことありますでしょうか
なんかアメリカでちょっと前にはやっ
てたらしいんですけどねこのスイカにアルコールの瓶のお酒ビンのお咲をぶっさして
こちら追加がアルコールをノームんですよ
それからあるコードのんじゃらしくてそしたらこのスイカの中にアルコールが浸透し
さあの歌詞おいしい3区になるらしいんですよ5マインパワー
行ってみようと思いますネットとかで見たやつはなく1本とか2本での腐ったってさ
せるんですけどもどんどん私もコンビニでありとあらゆる
口が細いピンの遅い買ってきましたセミの二アイスみかんのやつ
スパークリングワインサングリアべ某サワーこれを流す3のがポイントだけど桃のお酒
リンゴのお酒フルーツの先生からよくわかんねワインこれだけのお酒は全部この
スイング日記
ぶっさしてお前ベロンベロンに酔わせて廃校においしいアルコールのスイカ作って
みようと思います
吉田は早速いますよ言ってさすってこれどういった挿せばいいんだ何かあなたがもよう
に開けるかな
えっ
はバレそう
えーとえーとほんとどうすればいいかわかんないけど行け放送など穴あけてみますね
案内で ok 席でもダメみたいなこと書いてあったんですよね
そんな難しい事あると思ったんですけど
めちゃ臭いためっちゃいい感じに案内きましたねもうこれ早速ぶっさして良いんじゃ
ねーぞ早速分
いたしますこういうこと所はい
3つでるけど後寄せご利用ぜ
うそれ
えっ
おっはー
いうことだ分ちょっとずつ減ってでまあそう酒が
飲んでるぞこれいやすごいこういう感じちょっと考えさせていきましょう
一車
うってくるんだが上てくるんだがお客ハマタマタマタを競うですはいはい
あっはぁ
オフィシャに勢い大好きはいきます
パブーいい
おっしゃー
[音楽]
aae どうすんねんこれ
pa
う曲がっ
なんかものすごいことなってきてくる大丈夫か
ああああっ
準備だアーチャー
シャアドンドンドンドンウはもう神バランスだ
さあ言ってるわけ税務の詐欺さんしましたーー
バランスまずダメですそれはマジですっ
あの本店も言え夜間ないみたいなちょっとですけどこれやばい中井時でいかがでしょう
か
5全部のお酒はさしましたでもなんか
パーンすが悪いんですよ
なんか熱帯魚飼ってる友達の家の音みたいなのがします上から見てもすごいよこれ
すごいすごいすごい
見立なかなりかっこいいのではないのでしょうがえーっとなんか普通だとこんなものの
分じゃなくてなんか1日か2日ぐらい連続の中に置くらしいですそうするとお酒が浸透
してとても美味しくなるらしいです出船入れます
マジで重すぎてヤバイってどこに
てればいいじゃんっ
っとぜってー張りがあるよねこれチャイ入らねえこれぞストロングゼロ全部は数しか
ない
よしよし
最適でかなりのストロングゼロを脱出ことによってスペースが結構明けましたね走れが
垂れてきそうなんでもう先に聞いておきますったり寝れるはずこれであとは成果を
入れるだけです
マジで覚えこれマジで想い k 入れます
ん
ぶっぱ早っ
まあまあいんざす緊張ですかなっはい変だなぁなまたベンチに近いかなぁこれで言っ
てる時くらい放置してスイカにアルコールをしっかりと染み込ませてみたいと思います
果たしてどんな味になっているのでしょうか
おやすみ
配布盗みなさーい
上下2つ持っていきたいとおもいますガーンッ
ん
[音楽]
ええええええ
まあ見た目に変わりはないですね見た目に変わりはないですけどご覧くださいこれもう
お酒によってはなんですけども飲み干されてる奴もあります熱見るとが伸びこされてる
ぞ
中も方もないんだこれももないし mo さんはあんまり好きじゃなかったみたいです
から高さによって結構差はあるんですけども
2日間おけば結構限界までお酒を飲んでくれたのかなと思います愛と呼びでよく使うか
も
この
ゆうかちゃんはお酒は飲み続けたと思いますおつかれさまでした
よしこういうわけでさっそく食べていきましょうどうやってどうもどうやって行ってき
ますそれぞ先ほど行かないと始まらないんだよっての沈み役はもう全部飲み掘ってる
ねー
[音楽]
の花すぎでしょこれあの先輩名前だったまあしばかれてきたらまずでちょっとばないと
お前
おっ
絶対来れるこれ全部どうなんだい
中野を下げって好き嫌いがすごいな飲めるお酒は飲めるタイプですねこれはいい
もう住めってー
これはさすがに黒い行っても絶対こんなにフルーティーんしためっちゃ美味しいと思う
んですよねやちょっとマジで味はわからんけどとりあえず上げていきたいとおもいます
とりあえず今晩できればいいんだといいます
[音楽]
yoshiki 大大大大文学部ライフ
見た目が変わってない見た目はそんなに変わらなかったでもなんだ
雑感小池がスミスの色が入ってるってぺかすぎでしょ
マジででっけえスイカたなこれはいというわけでさっそく食べてみたいと思います腐っ
てないよねー
あのかっ台風なんかグッズ縁はしてないからこれでたらしいなと思う
はたしてどんな味になってるんでしょうか
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
あさん
チャールこりゃすごいお酒感が出ても誰
わぁお酒やばいねこれから入り過ぎたらびっくりするぐらいお酒感が強いですねます
か美味しいよね今日するんですよね
うーんあうまいわでも
[音楽]
まじもこれは多分をサンディがかかってないところ美味しいんだな
あのう
ブーブーブーブー l パッケージ
いやでもこれね大酒好きな人だったら絶対好きなんすよ僕なんか結構カクテルとかでも
2階の無理なんでちょっとお酒になってきれいな人からすると普通のスピーカー方が
美味しいかなという気がしましたぜ体を避け好きな人からするとたマンでフルーツなん
だと思いますとりあえずさすがにこれは一人で食うとして残りは
[音楽]
ん
みんな
[音楽]